good afternoon everybody
Peter salivate president Peter salivate
and all
welcome to the second of this year's
Tanner lectures on human values by a
shilling been a professor at the
University of the Witwatersrand in
Johannesburg and at the vits
Institute for social and economic
research at that University quick
introduction today we don't we don't we
don't stand on too much formality on the
second day of the Tanners I remember
please that we will reconvene here
tomorrow morning at 10:30 for the final
event of this year's Tanner's and that
is a panel discussion among professor
and Bembe and Yale professors in der pol
gruel and Michael Denning I was in a
funny conversation a couple of days ago
with a seal and Michael about those
occasions where you give a talk and then
someone stands up afterwards to
summarize it and you think to yourself
did I really talk about that so I won't
today risk take the risk of summarizing
a Shield's lecture from yesterday but
only signal a few of his themes remind
you of a few of its themes and hope that
he might recognize the signals as
something he did indeed talk about we
learned yesterday about the new mobility
regime of the lectures title and its
implications for the changing nature of
borders and their effects in our world
we heard about the border as a zone of
securitization and control and about
three different approaches to theorizing
this zone approaches that characterized
those against whom the border is
mobilized in terms of precarity
in terms of extreme vulnerability of
detention incarceration violence but we
also had a glimpse of something more
hopeful a border as a place even of
rescue and we heard finally
fascinatingly on at some length about an
existential flip by which the features
of borders at land and sea have been
exchanged the fluidity of sea borders
described theorized made almost mythic
by Carl Schmitt has now been transferred
to land borders this has happened
because we live in that mobility regime
of a seals title the medium of land
borders is no longer land but has become
a fluid medium and what does this medium
consist of the tens of millions of
displaced human bodies defining new
border zones by their movements zones
then not limited to liminal spaces but
extending everywhere those movements
reach this might also look like a
hopeful development and perhaps we will
see how it is so in today's lecture
entitled the idea of a borderless world
but not so fast because Ashiya was quick
to remind us that in the era of
digitized biometrics and securitized
borders even the fluid motions of
millions can be tracked and controlled
we will find out I feel
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much Gary I indeed
recognize myself in the in the brilliant
summary obvious this lecture you have
just given us I would also like to thank
the president of the university Peter
who is with us this evening
yesterday I intimated that the
government of mobility might well be one
of the most important problems to
confront the world during the first half
of the 21st century the capacity to
decide who can move who can settle where
and under what conditions is
increasingly becoming the core of
political struggles over sovereignty
over nationalism citizenship identity
security and freedom
I strongly suggested that with Western
colonial expansion and more decisively
with the advent of capitalism the Rezo
net of the border is to attend to key
questions such as to whom does the earth
belong who can lay what types of claims
to what parts of it and to the rest
beings who inhabit them who determines
its distribution or partition in framing
the question of the border in this way I
was trying to show that the power of the
border lies in its capacity to regulate
or are called multiple distributions of
populations
and by population I mean humans and
non-humans their distribution on the
body of the earth and in so doing to
affect the vital forces of all kinds of
beings I also argued that as the 21st
century and Falls a global renewed
desire from both citizens and their
respective states for a tighter control
of mobility is evident indeed wherever
we look the drive is towards inclusion
or in any case towards an
intensification of the directrix of
territorial ization and detail
colonization the dialectics of opening
and inclusion the belief that the world
would be safer if only risks ambiguity
and uncertainty could be controlled and
if only identities could be fixed once
for all and secured that belief is
gaining momentum and risk management
techniques increasingly becoming a means
to govern mobilities such techniques are
indeed proliferating in particular I
highlighted the extent to which as gary
was reminding us the biometric border is
extending into multiple realities not
only of social life but of the body that
body are called the body that is not is
not mine tonight I would like to pursue
this line of argument concerning the
redistribution of the earth not only
through the control of bodies but also
through the control of movement itself
and its core
speed which indeed is what migration
control policies are all about
controlling bodies but also movement
itself and its corollary speed more
specifically I would like to see whether
and under what conditions we could
re-engineer the Utopia of borderless
Africa and by extension a borderless
world since as far as I know an Africa
is part of the world and the world is
it's part of Africa I would like to do
that taking into consideration the
contemporary matrix of flows closures
and circulations including the secretion
of various forms of capital now you will
ask me but why is it important to attend
once again to what is obviously a
utopian intent the question of a
borderless world I think it's important
for a number of reasons the first which
is let's say a philosophical reason is
that from its inception movement or more
precisely borderless iners has been
central to various utopian traditions
when you look at the very concept of
utopia that is what it refers to it
refers to that which has no borders
beginning with the imagination itself I
think the power of utopianism results in
its ability to instantiate the tension
between born lessness movement and place
attention if we look carefully that has
marked social transformations in the
modern era
this 10 she continues in contemporary
discussions of movement based social
processes particularly international
migration open borders transnationalism
and even cosmopolitanism when you read
[ __ ] on cosmopolitanism Khan's discourse
on cosmopolitanism is traversed from one
end to the other by this tension between
board lessness plays and a movement so
it seems to me that in this context the
idea of a borderless world can be a
powerful and bet Pro Matic resource for
social political and even aesthetic
imagination the second reason is that
precisely because of the current atrophy
of the utopian imagination
apocalyptic imaginaries and narratives
of cataclysmic disasters and unknown
futures have colonized the spirit of our
Terms find Amira way popular culture in
political discourses in cinema in music
they're everywhere indeed some of the
ecological anxieties and fantasies of
the Apocalypse I would argue are the
product of the Anthropocene
but what politics the visions of future
catastrophe and gender if not a politics
of separation rather than a politics of
the humanity as species coming into
being as stewards of the earth because
we inherited history in which the
consistent sacrifice of some lives for
the betterment of
others is the norm and because these are
times of deep-seated anxieties including
anxieties of racialized others taking
over the planet because of all of that
racial violence is increasingly encoded
in the language of the border and in the
language of security as a result
contemporary borders are in danger of
becoming sites of reinforcement
reproduction and intensification of
vulnerability for stigmatized and
dishonored groups for the most racially
marked the ever more disposable those
that in this era of a neoliberal
abandonment have been paying the
heaviest price of prices for the most
expensive period of prison construction
in human history refer to the prison
here precisely to the casual landscapes
of a world precisely as the antithesis
of movement of freedom of movement there
is no dramatic opposite to of the idea
of freedom of movement than prison and
the prison is key feature of the
landscapes of our time so in proposing
to reexamine the question of borderless
Africa and a borderless world I would
like to stay away from dominant ways in
which this issue has easily been dealt
with that is under the sign of Kant and
his promise of unbounded cosbo
Tennyson and I would likely stay away
from the other dominant approach to the
question of a borderless world one under
the sign of liberal individualism
understood as an antidote or to the
deeply ingrained fascist impulses of
European governments and bureaucracies
who amen referring yesterday at dinner
with Gary to a very important chapter in
an arrant important classic book the
origins of totalitarianism as chapter 2
it's called race and bureaucracy the
reference I have just made has alludes
to indeed that chapter which as I was
signaling for some unknown reasons has
not really been the object of major
consideration so for those of you who
are looking for a topic for your
decision there's one right there
chapter 2 the origins of totalitarianism
so I'd love to stay away from these two
modes of approaching the question of a
borderless world both of them in fact
although they seem to be worse apart
have something in common
they both articulated around a concept
you might hopefully know of the concept
of the fourth freedom in classical
liberal thought
there are three core freedoms
first of all freedom of movement and
within freedom of movement movement of
of capital of course priority number one
course there is no capital without goods
the freedom of movement of goods and
more and more especially in these times
of ours
number three services freedom movement
of those who can provide services those
are the three freedoms the three core
freedoms so the concept of fourth
freedom has to do with the movement of
persons so traditional engagements with
the idea of a borderless world aim at
precipitating the advent of that fourth
freedom which is fair movement of
persons and within that configuration a
borderless world would look something
like this it would be a world of free
movement of capital of goods services
and persons and such movement such
freedom of movement would not be
restricted to the core economically rich
countries or states which is the case as
we speak that the Schengen system for
instance is limited to the core European
countries in fact if you have an
American passport you can basically go
wherever you want the world belongs to
you but this is not the case
every inhabitant of our planet so in the
configuration have just referred to the
fourth freedom the ability to move
around the planet would no longer
limited to put it crudely to Europeans
and to Americans it would be radical
right that would belong to everybody by
virtue of each and every individual
being human being so it's a right that
would be extended including to poor
members of the earth so you see we go
back to this question of the earth there
would be no visas meaning in some let's
see in sensations of the fourth freedom
movement there would be no visas there
would be no quotas there wouldn't be any
bizarre category to fill first of all
because you wouldn't have to apply for a
visa so wouldn't have to feel anything
they there would be no applications
procedures preceding any animals which
means that one could just get on a plane
on a train on a boat on the road on a
bag rights of non-discrimination would
be extended to all so a borderless world
would be the world in which secretory
and pendulum migrations would be the
norm with in fact longer term
settlements less likely since borders
would be easy and open
I will give you one little example
please when I was growing up I mean not
so long ago
don't don't believe Gary when he sees me
we met feet 25 years ago we did but but
we were both very very young so not so
long ago I was born in Cameroon Cameroon
used to be a German Protectorate which
became after the first world war divided
between the winning powers England on
the one hand and France on the other I
was born in the French part of Cameroon
and until the beginning of the 80s it
was possible to travel to France with
one's identity card
national identity card most people went
to France and came back they didn't go
there because they wanted to settle
there most people want to live where
they belong current good but they want
to be able to come and go and they are
more likely to come and go when the
borders are not hermetically closed so
the borderless world imagined by the
fourth freedom movement is premise
therefore on these rights of
non-discrimination and on this
circulatory and pendular set of
migrations now let me move on one go
further into those debates they are both
complicated and quite straightforward we
have those who support free movement of
neighbor and those who believe that it
only intensifies levels of exploitation
especially of migrants we can talk about
it during the discussions what I really
want to do now is to still in this
attempt at elucidating or posing
differently the question of a borderless
world what I would like to do is to
contrast two paradigms on the one hand
the examine the liberal idea of a
borderless world through the free
movement
let's see concept so contrast it with
african critical oniel understandings of
movement in space that's what I want to
do in the hope that in contrasting these
two paradigms we might begin to let's
say this will give us conceptual
resources to expand on this utopian
project for more news world when I say
liberal classical thought of course it
is extremely complicated you understand
that I don't have the time to go into
all the nuances I'm giving you a kind of
archetype which needs to be itself
properly deconstructed and here I will
rely in particular on a recently
published work called movement and the
authoring of freedom I just keep in mind
that idea of the ordering of freedom
it's a work not has been published by
Haga Kotov and Israeli scholar who
teaches at the School of Oriental and
African Studies in London and you might
you might let your imagination work and
understand why it is that it's an
Israeli who who is let's see interesting
nice so what Hegar shows in that work is
the extent to which liberal thought
liberal political thought has in fact
always been shattered with a
contradiction when it comes to imagining
the possibility of a borderless world
and her argument is that this
contradiction which i will elicit in a
moment stems from its conception of
movement she shows that in fact two
dominant configurations of movement
constantly come into conflict with each
other the terms cancel each other within
classical liberal thought movement here
is seen both as a manifestation of
freedom and as an interruption of order
as a threat to order and one of the
functions of the state is therefore to
craft a concept of order and stability
and security that is reconcilable with
its concept of freedom and its concept
of movement that is the the
contradiction
and to some extent agar argues the
liberal classical state is the enemy of
people who restlessly move around
why because such people are configured
as and in a similar bill alternate EU
cannot assimilate them they are
constantly on the move and in fact they
are courier repercussions of all of this
I mean when colonialism said to set foot
in in Africa for instance the biggest
problem of the colonial state in the
content of Africa from the 19th century
on is to make sure that people stay in
the same place it has a hard time
bringing them to stay in the same place
because the state believes that they are
constantly on the move they are current
coat and captured so the business of a
state is how to capture them because why
do you want to capture them you want to
capture them precisely because without
capturing them sovereignty doesn't mean
anything sovereignty means you capture
people you capture a territory you
delimited borders and this allows you in
turn to exercise the different types of
monopolies Max Weber spoke about a
monopoly over of course territory a
monopoly over the people monopoly in
terms of the use of legitimate force and
very importantly because everything else
depends on that monopoly over taxation
but you can't tax people who whose
who have no address today here tomorrow
morning they going for an ant or dunker
and next week they have moved to a
different entirely location so the state
sees such people as enemies both of
freedom because they abuse freedom they
do not see size it with restraint and
enemies of security and order
you can't build an order on the basis of
of that which is unstable so that's a
very important aspect of let's see what
classical liberal theory tells us about
movement the same state is a friend of
self regulated movement why because
freedom is here understood as being
about moderation
it's what self-regulation is known about
excess excessive movement immediately
conjures problems of security and bad
movement is seen as a threat and a quote
haha freedom is only political valuable
if it relies on some mechanisms that
regulate the movement that manifested a
quote her quoting Hobbes
so as katifaq argues movement only had
to be restrained via an array of
disciplinary mechanisms
it had to be reconciled with freedom and
to some extent self restraint but the
ability to restrain oneself or to
regulate oneself was not assumed to be
the share of all subjects
that is not everybody who is able to
restrain himself or herself and some
movements were therefore configured as
freedom and others were deemed improper
anyway conceived as a threat that's the
bifurcation we have in classical liberal
thought and what point is it that a
specific kind of movement by specific
kinds of subjects is or is not a threat
that's the spectrum that haunts
classical liberal state from those years
up to now we haven't got rid of that
spectrum so the way in which classical
liberal states have tried to resolve
this contradiction has been by putting
forward the idea of managed mobility
which by the way is back on the agenda
right now speak in Europe and even in
South Africa I've been doing some work
with the Department of Home Affairs on
recalibrating in traffic and migrations
the country concept is managed mobility
so within the framework of managed
mobility and because of the perceived
aberrant movements certain categories of
the population are constantly seen as
posing a threat not only to themselves
to their own security but also to others
of the security and such a threat
it is thought can be diminished if their
movements are confined and if they are
domesticated and subject to some form or
not over phone
and this is not new in fact this has
been typical indeed of the ways in which
different figures of mobility
historically have become the foundation
upon which different modes of governance
where were produced in it in the West
generally taken such way of such one
such Board of governance has been has
consisted in instituting what is called
a racial border that you have physical
borders but you also have racial border
such was the case under colonialism such
was the case of course in slave owning
and settler colonial societies in all
those places where settler liberty and
freedom of movement required the
criminalization of countless others and
such instances of criminalization
stigmatization became indispensable
features of liberal government I could
go on and on on that but let me move on
we can pick it up during the discussion
let me just capture water have tried to
say in one or two sentences just for you
to be able to keep in mind because I'll
be moving on and contrasting this model
with the African pre-colonial model so
in in the classical liberal model I was
referring to security and freedom
precisely because of the racial border
which some of us are particularly
interested in security and freedom came
to be defined as a right of exclusion
order within that model is about
securing the unequal ordering of
property relations that's what it is and
asserting the boundaries of the nation
goes hand-in-hand in that model with the
assertion of the boundaries of race now
defining the boundaries of race within
that model requires a proper definition
of the boundaries of the body as I was
arguing is the thus the centrality of
the body in the calculus of both freedom
and security now let's look into what
are called the African model
here again it's a very complex
consolation for lack of time I will go
straight to what matters and then we
will disaggregate it later first of all
let me say that pre Korea Africa might
not have been a borderless world this in
the sense in which we have been defining
borders since yesterday but where they
existed borders were always porous and
permeable that in fact the business of a
border is to be crossed
that's all it that is what borders are
for but there is no border conceivable
border are sort of the principle the law
of permeability I can give you countless
practical examples to instantiate this
but just believe me for the time being
that is what that's how it was as
evidence by traditions of long distance
trade situation was fundamental it was
fundamental in the production of
cultural forms of political forms of
economic and social and religious forms
the most important vehicle for
transformation and change was mobility
it was not a mean class struggles in the
sense we understand it it was mobility
mobility was the motor of any kind of
social or economic political
transformation
in fact it was the driving principle
behind the delimitation and organization
of space and territories so the
primordial principle of spatial
organization was movement was continuous
movement and it was still part of
present-day culture to stop is to run
risk you have to be on the move
constantly more and more especially in
conditions of crisis be on the move as
very condition of your own survival
because if you are not on the move the
chances of survival are diminished so
dominance to dominate sovereignty was
not exclusively expressed through the
control of territory physically marked
with borders it was not now you'll ask
me but how was it then if you cannot
control achieve her career exercise
sovereignty
how can you extract anything since as
far as we know power expresses itself
manifests itself also if not primarily
through one or the other form of
extraction of something all of that or
it spreads through networks networks
crossroads for those of you who are
familiar with African literature
the importance of robes and crossroads
in African literature is astounded me
read
shalinka read Chinua Achebe a masala
roots and crossroads are everywhere
in in that literature so crossroads
flows of people and flows of nature both
in dialectical relationship because in
those cosmogony x' people are thinking
without what we call nature so the
realization I mean the the the
Anthropocene turned which seems to be a
novelty in parts of our world today we
have always lived in that is not new
because you cannot think of people who
are thinking of nonhumans and here again
when Rick to Tala is a world of humans
nonhumans interacting acting with others
what Latour and others have called her
this rigid agency typical of those kinds
of let's say metaphysics of the human
and non-human now I want to exaggerate
this to be sure fixed geographical
places such as towns and villages did
exist people and things could be
concentrated in a particular location
and such places could even become the
origin of movement and there were links
between places links such as roads are
mentioned them flight paths
but places were not described by points
or by lines what mattered the most was
the distribution of movement between
places movement was the driving force of
the production of space and movement
itself if we were to believe some of
those cosmogony here have in mind
the Dogon cosmology cosmogony that way
particularly studied by Marcel Creole
all other cosmo granese in equatorial
africa dealt with by anthropologists
such as and historians such as Ian van
Zena Johnson and others movement itself
was not necessarily akin to displacement
it was what mattered the most was the
extent to which flows and the
intensities intersected and interacted
with other flows the new forms they
could take when they intensified so
movement especially among the Dogon
could lead to divergence it could lead
to convergence it could lead to
intersections and convergence divergence
and intersection were more important
than points they were more important
than lines they were more important than
surfaces lines points and surfaces as we
know being Cardinal referenced in
Western geometrics so what we have here
is let's say a different kind of
geometry it's a different entirely
different kind of geometry which are of
which concepts of borders concepts of
power concepts of relations concepts of
separation derive so the point is if we
want to
harness alternative resources conceptual
vocabulary type of that to imagine a
borderless world here is an archive I'm
not saying that is the only one but what
we have to harness are the archives of
the world at large and not only the
Western archive because in fact in the
western part I've there was no active
doesn't help us to develop an idea of
borderless nests the Western archive is
premised on the crystallization of the
idea of the border that we have to check
later on I'm just saying it as a
provocation so I could go on and on on
these alternative geometries let me just
add one or two things in this
configuration wealth and power only see
wealth in people are always trumped
wealth in things there were two forms of
wealth
it could be wealthy in terms of your
capacity to agglomerate around you
clients family members and so forth and
so on or you could be wealthy just by
virtue of having accumulated a huge
amount of quantity of things so see here
the nexus of quantities and qualities
qualities of persons categories of
persons being at play here and multiple
forms of membership were always of
you would be astonished you take one
society and look into the dictionary of
forms of membership how is it that one
below whoa
through what window is it that you can
enter the house multiple forms of
membership not kind of rigid
classification where even you are a
citizen or you are a foreigner in
between being a citizen and being a
foreigner there was a whole repertoire
of alternative forms of membership and
building alliances through trade
marriage or religion in cooperating
newcomers refugees asylum seekers into
existing policies that was the norm you
dominate by integrating foreigners all
kinds of foreigners and just to see
after what I've just said peoplehood not
talking about nationhood people who'd
included not only the living there also
the dead and the unborn humans and
nonhumans exactly in line with all we
are being told about in this age of the
Anthropocene and community was
unthinkable without some kind of
foundational date you know there are too
many but two principal forms of date
there is a kind of death that is I would
say it's proprietary kind of debt I mean
banks we some of some of you some of us
in debt to banks can you pay interest if
you don't pay interest they wake up one
morning and the amount of to pay for the
interest has overtaken the amount you
borrowed in the first instance so that
the form of debt are called X
proprietary but in this constellation
human constellation talking about
there's a different kind of debt that is
constitutive of their very basis of the
relation and it's a kind of debt that
encompasses not only the living the now
well so those who came before and those
who will come after us that we have
obligations to that chain of beings
which include once again not only humans
but animals but what we call nature and
so forth and so on okay I can come back
to that if you want to have further
comments so you see what I'm getting
so those are the two models once again
these are archetypes we have to be
properly history sized what are the
social forces driving what what are the
limits we all understand that so where
are we to today it seems to me that
worldwide the combination of fast
capitalism and we mention it yesterday
the saturation of the everyday by
digital and computational technologies
these two things have led to the
acceleration of speed and the
intensification of connections in fact
the world is so connected today today
basically you can sit where you are you
have access to your technologies and you
have access to an amount of knowledge we
have never had access to that is going
on at the same time willful ignorance is
a feature of our times how come we know
so less when the amount of knowledge we
have has never been as astounding as it
is whatever the case it seems to me that
ours is in this regard an era of
planetary entanglement but this is not
all as Paul Virilio video is a French
scholar but not only him countless
others have suggested the twin
phenomenon of immediacy and instant
annuity is presently
one of the most pressing problems
confronting us or in any case one of the
most determining factors assuring a new
technological epoch since yesterday I
have been bringing in the discs trying
to bring in discussion this event which
is our emergence into a new
technological age because we can't
simply understand what's going on
if we don't factor in this new
technological development so it seems to
me that in line with the earlier and the
others that one of the the most pressing
problems confronting us assuring us into
this new technological epoch has to
indeed with the twin phenomena of
insanity and images so in considering
what borders have become the kind of
work they are doing today not yesterday
now or in considering what a borderless
world or Burness Africa might look like
it might be useful to take seriously the
possibility that real time now prevails
above both real space and the geosphere
in general and that's really the key
argument I would like to push tonight
the super session of real space by real
time something that is made possible
precisely because of our because of this
techno political event that is driven by
all we have been referring to since
yesterday the primacy of real time of
image
you see and insanity over and above
space over and above territory over and
above surface might not yet be
irreversible but it is in the process of
becoming what we could call a fait
accompli even if we wanted to reverse it
it might be to me that what a fella
complete is a fair completes also by the
way that which nobody can account for so
question of an accountability the
impossibility to account for or the
difficulty to account for which means
the difficulty to take responsibility
for in fact of the three main physical
barriers science teaches us marry off
sound of heat and light the first two
have already been felled the sound
barrier and here quadrennial has been
cut across by the super and hypersonic
aircraft while the heat barrier is
penetrated by the Rockets taking human
beings outside the Earth's orbit in
order to land them on the moon but the
third barrier Silverio speaking that of
light is not something one can cross you
crash into it it is precisely this
barrier of time which confronts history
in the present day he adds so building
on the rigorous remarks we can argue
that the moment Humanity will reach the
light barium that is the speed of light
the historical event of unprecedented
importance will happen which might throw
history itself in this ray and my jumble
up the relation of the living beings
towards the world what do I mean by that
by that I mean when it happens then we
will have entered a borderless world
we'll enter a borderless world when let
me put it differently when humanity
reaches the light battery because
territory it won't vanish it will still
be there but it will become irrelevant
it'll become irrelevant because
precisely we will have finally
domesticated absolute speed and having
done so
the earth will enter a new period of its
deep history one in which real time will
really have superseded real space so let
me just say that we are not yet there we
might not get there in our lifetime some
of us at least but take for instance
algorithmic trading also known as
high-frequency trading
computerized fully automated it is
obvious that algo financial markets but
one dimension of the ecology of
high-speed materiality that is
transforming not only the nature of
market access in our time but also I
should add the very nature of borders
and in that sense it's not simply a
technological development so what I'm
arguing for is that in order to imagine
borderless world we have to go beyond
the liberal idea of movement and speed
and somewhat
draw from other archives I'll end it all
of this now by putting on the table an
ocean I take from the Ghanaian
Constitution the Ghanaian consider of
Ghana has developed concept I haven't
found any way Ellis it is the concept a
new right they call the right of a boat
[ __ ] de as a fundamental right that is
they want to add to the list of
traditional human rights it seems to me
that this idea of the right of a boat is
a cornerstone for any real imagination
of Africa as a borderless space in
cities because in a if Africa is to
contribute to the unfolding global
debate on human mobility in this age of
territory entitlement it needs to indeed
dig deeply into its own archives in a
world in which arrest detention
incarceration including at sea
abandonment deportation seen as the most
efficient ways of dealing with economic
migrants refugees asylum seekers we
should draw from our own historical
perspective experience as African and
desperate people an articular proposal
for ourselves and for the world which is
radically different from the
anti-humanist norms and practices
currently prevalent on matters
concerning Manila human ability in the
world a city's because at a deep
historical level African diasporic
struggles for freedom and
self-determination have always been
intertwined with the aspiration to move
and cheat whether under conditions of
slavery planted slavery trans-saharan
slavery under colonial rule the loss of
our sovereignty automatically resulted
in the loss of our right to free
movement this is the reason why the
dream of a free redeemed and multi
African nation what Marcus Garvey called
a bright star among the constellation of
Nations this is why this dream has been
inextricably linked to the recovery of
the right to come and go with our let or
hindrance across our colossal continent
in fact history in modernity has been to
a large extent one of constant
displacement and confinement
forced migrations and coerced labor
think of the plantation system in the
Americas and the Caribbean think of the
Black Codes the big loss or the vagrancy
status after the failure of
reconstruction in the United States in
1887 think of the chain gangs laboring a
task such as road construction ditch
digging tearing deforestation and so for
the zone think 2 of the code the land
Aegina in French color in Africa of the
Bantu stands and labour reserves in
southern Africa and of the castle
industrial complex in today's United
States of America in each instance to be
African and to be black has meant to be
consigned to one or the other of the
many spaces of confinement modernity
invented the Scramble for Africa in the
19th century and the carving of its
boundaries along colonial lines turned
the continent into a massive castle
space and each of us into a potential
illegal migrant unable to move except
under increasingly punitive conditions
as a matter of fact entrapment became
the precondition for the exploitation of
labour which is why the struggles for
emancipation and racial upliftment were
so intertwined with the struggles for
the right to move freely so if we want
to conclude the work of decolonization
we have to bring down colonial
boundaries
and turn Africa into a vast space of
circulation for itself for his
descendants and for anyone who wants to
tie his or her faith with our continent
that's the importance of the concept of
the right of abode as written in the
Ghanaian Constitution thank you very
much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so you talk eloquently about the
importance of movement without visas and
without you know any kind of application
process and it's very moving to think of
it in those terms you know in terms of
the traditional Constitution of Africa
as the Castro space but at the same time
you also talk about the importance of
indebtedness that we're indebted to the
debt and to some extent we're also
indebted or we can be held answerable to
to the future - descendants it seems to
me that the to actually point in
slightly different directions in the
sense that being indebted or
knowledgeable were [ __ ] in there that
whatever that one formula or another
either forward-looking about backward
looking that puts us in a kind of a
sequel in which we do occupy a space
that is not cannot be freely linked
relinquish so I just wonder if you could
comment a little bit about the sense of
unbounded mobility on the one hand and
the sense of being obligated and being
held by our obligation which implies a
certain kind of constraint should we
take a few questions
so my question pertains a little bit to
the the porous borders in some cases it
does seem that there are regimes or
Arrangements where borders are becoming
more porous but the exchange is extreme
surveillance and monitor monitoring and
I can think of a few cases where it's
relatively easy to enter various spaces
countries but the exchange is that
there's better biometric information is
eluded to but also better surveillance
whether it's monitoring you via your
phone via satellite via drone and I
wonder if perhaps one of the directions
that some of these arrangements might be
going in is you can go wherever you want
but we're going to know exactly what
you're doing where you are who you're
meeting with so there's a freedom of
movement but there's no longer really a
freedom to anonymity or to privacy
thanks
see I was I was up
to have my own convictions on on each of
issues I put on the table I was I can
talk about that I was trying to offer a
way in which we can recapture in these
times of utopian and atrophy we can
recapture the utopian resources that are
embedded in the idea of a world that
wouldn't have any border and in
particular a continent for the reasons I
mentioned at the end that would become
really free for its people and and and
would speak to the world from that
position so so that's the framework I
was trying to to build and of course as
far as unbounded mobility is concerned
and I think that it's a a project we
have to take seriously we have to take
it seriously and whether or not it is
actually feasible in fact we have to
hold dear onto it precisely at the
moment when it appears to to be totally
totally utopian I argue in that way for
all kinds of reasons one of which has to
do with what I really believe is the our
entry into a planetary age and then this
doesn't mean that nation-states don't
exist any longer they are still there
I'm not subscribing to the kind of
discourse of happy globalization we
witnessed
in in the nineties when many believe
that in fact nation-states way we're
going to disappear if anything they have
shown that they are extremely resilient
and they can mutate with the times so I
have to hold on on to that precisely
because in spite of their existence none
of the issues we humanity is dealing
with today can result at a national
level alone so I put forward this
renewal idea in the hope that these
renewed planetary consciousness might
force us to address the questions I was
putting for years day whose earth is
this rather than host countries this how
do we distribute it meaning not how I
conquer it for ourselves but meaning how
do we share it how do we share it
because sharing it is the very condition
of its sustainability at the moment when
the possibility of extinction is is real
it is plausible it's not it's not
implausible so the question of
inhabitation
of the world at large of the earth the
question of sharing it as a condition
for its own durability those questions
become extremely important especially if
we want to move beyond just an
ethnographic description of how borders
work and and the kind of work they they
accomplish so if we want the project is
to inject contemporary debates
on migration movement mobility with the
kind of philosophical and theoretical
urgency that is made available to us
with the realization that we have
entered techno planetary age and then
the questions of unboundedness and
obligation to locality it seems to me
they can be reshaped differently that
would be a way of let's see commenting
on on your comments and you see on the
one hand if I limit myself to the
continent what we are really witnessing
is a double process one of closure the
other one of an acceleration in terms of
opening of African borders now there are
27 countries in the continent way if you
are have an African passport you can
obtain your visa at arrival that wasn't
the case two three years ago it's now
the case last week they signed in Kigali
a new treaty same kind of treaties mean
you see we were NAFTA and the rest so
they are moving you know those
directions want a free market for the
whole continent but as I was suggesting
the the it seems to me that the the the
the most plausible way probably to to to
dismantle national borders in the
continent might have to go through
domestication of of new technologies I
really believe that the paradoxically
not that technologies are neutral but
but but they are the the most direct way
in which colonial boundaries in Africa
will fall I can give you plenty of
examples of Harvey is already happening
so so on the one hand borders are
becoming a bit more porous than before
but on the other hand there is a global
drive to to turn the continent into into
a castle space very few Africans are
welcomed as migrants anywhere in the
world you give me one example of
Africans arriving in any part of the
world where they are welcomed Europe in
its attempt at reinforcing in southern
boundaries is actively recruiting the
number of transit countries in in making
sure that its borders are extended in
the continent itself but you can't have
a situation where people cannot go out
and they cannot circulate from within
that double penalty is it seems to me
one of the biggest threats to movement
of people right now
um I I was just listening to you today
and yesterday I was thinking about well
I was reminded of what if Danny does
deep frustration with cants and his
frustration was that Cod restricted his
concept of cosmopolitanism to the right
of visitation and hardly ever to the
right of residence and it seems to me
that what is central to your talk what
was central to your talk today and
you'll talk yesterday was the idea of
moving freely and I wonder if you could
perhaps talk a bit more about the tween
question of settling freely of the right
to settle freely as opposed to move
freely settle settle settle settle
residence I suppose to visit okay oh
okay I see
so settling as opposed to moving frankly
I don't know why I didn't pay attention
to to settle II
[Music]
maybe because because of the antecedent
sitting sedentary bias that is my own
bias but I have a feeling that I mean
what we got all encouraged to do today
is just to settle stay well especially
stay where you are
just stay where you are don't don't move
around and and therefore I was not
interested in that that part and and I
haven't thought about it
I don't think that is the problem today
I don't know what do you think but it
seems to mean that I mean we are all
encouraged to stay where we are no
travel too much not settle as well just
just be where we belong and so the best
way to shake that is to look into the
opposite which is how do we make sure
that we move how do we make sure that
settlement is not the same as
confinement which has been meaning some
people's histories in the plantation and
and if you you move then it's an attempt
it's a crime against property so I
haven't thought about it but I will
think about it yes I want to say thank
you you've given us so much to think
about and powerful images for thinking
differently about the world we're in in
it your account of Africa resonated very
much with our thinking about the
Americas where migrants are clamoring
for the right not to migrate as well as
the right to migrate and they link the
protection of mobility to the
possibility of restoration of home and
are also asking for something besides
the path to citizenship as the means to
achieve and redeem themselves as persons
with protection and legal status so your
critique of the liberal framework about
freedom and security is is very well
taken my question is for the economics a
bit within this technology my work
recently I've been looking at the use of
x-ray
and the trucking and I think it goes to
this question about settling is that
there is a category of people who in the
imagination of this they are not meant
to live socially right and in relation
but to be the surplus who can be brought
and left so that along with immobility
is the forced migration and the guest
worker program and the category of
existence in which they live so long
away from home that they no longer have
that capacity of social and relation or
where because they're incarcerated the
future growth of their population in the
US will be limited right where there's a
bio political project around race but
the work that I've been doing with x-ray
and I wanted to hear you talk more about
the body is an optic of state control of
looking inside the body that is doing
something different from it seems to me
other regimes of race and racial
profiling you've said very powerfully
the way it travels with the person and
becomes part of the person's biography
and works against the capacity of the
person to represent themselves but it
also it seems to me is really again
linked to this production of an ideal
non person who can be made into a unit
of work a unit of value even as they're
represented in political discourse as
the refuse of nations as people who are
in their improper place or who are
surplus do you know what I mean so
there's there's the discourse that says
these are the surplus people right who
no longer really who are improperly here
but they're being produced as
non-persons
in the way statelessness for an economic
function in ways that I'd love to hear
you maybe think about with me because I
hear very much the the beautiful work
that you've done around the political
order of things I just wanted to ask you
to think the economic logic of that
border space a little bit more if you
get my question I have too many
questions at once I think my problem
will deal with some of them tomorrow
looking at garyun and Peter and in the
clock
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]